[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are going to explore the
question when is fun
too dangerous oh I never much fun you
remember that country song Kershaw too
much fun what's that mean I don't know
it's it's who sing it
I don't know sure I know I think it was
it's somebody that may not have had
another country hit in the 90s after
that one but yeah we're gonna yeah I
think what we're gonna end up doing is
something dangerous I've started know
I've started thinking back on a lot of
the dangerous hobby type things that
we've done and I've gotten I've gotten a
little scared
yeah and I've done a little research on
some statistics you know some numbers
that will help us get the truth about
how dangerous things are compared to how
dangerous we perceive them to be
okay and then I hope that at the end of
this conversation we will have arrived
at what we are saying is our personal
philosophy of balancing fun in danger
which you can take or leave a rubric a
rubric if you will a room of rubrics
cube now a rubric a system built upon
which we can then navigate life's
decisions that's what I think of rubric
is okay I'll take Christy it's your wife
she taught high school math our first
year of marriage she was a geometry
teacher very dangerous she referred to
her rubric a lot and I think that was
like the plans that were given to her
for what she had to how she had to
navigate teaching like a syllabus I
never I've never looked up what the word
means I just kind of sensed what it
means and now we're gonna come up with
an adventure danger report that shows a
lot of hubris
the fact that you're saying rubric so
we're gonna do that
um but I'll give you a little bit of
update I got a houseguest hey you know
I'm not big on houseguests I know that
no I don't never let me stay over I
might like my my home is my zone man and
it's it's a I just don't let anybody
come in there you let people you just
people just transient in and out of your
house well that is because of my
wonderful wife who has the gift of
hospitality
yeah let's there is a positive spin to
there and she's very open and she's very
welcoming and we in she's anyways well
but she if if I lived at your house even
though if we lived at your house even
and we had three kids
we still without a guest room like my
wife he'd find a way my wife would have
two of those kids in one room together
right because she really believes in the
concept of a guest room a lot of
pressure make people happy it's like a
freaking bed-and-breakfast you ought to
see what she does for these people maybe
I'll come over next time I'm in the
doghouse can I just stay in the
McLaughlin B&B I don't know do you do
you like her old great team no okay well
you're not welcome yeah I know you have
one of those Nespresso machines so don't
try to pull one over on me and that'll
be in my room when I'm staying there
anyway and we do make exceptions there
for the print ones in the guest room
that I gotta say if I got to print
something I'm coming in I'm barging in I
have a key oh is it dot-matrix is it
gonna wake me up like it's laser oh nice
laser printer that's cool man you know
medium medium volume okay sorry to
interrupt you but I do make exceptions
occasionally especially for family
members and especially for family
members that are famous are famous and
potentially becoming more famous if you
follow me on Twitter
look at that link Lamont you need to
shout out to Twitter link Lamont you
care you guys shout out to link Lamont
on Twitter yeah that's how you do it you
got to do it a lot to get better I
haven't done it in quite a bit but you
know what I start
my mantle take the mantle taking the
mantle piece then you know that for a
certain
a time in conjunction with the broadcast
of the most recent season of this is the
vise singing competition show not the
American Idol one yeah the other one
with with that the the country singer
and the rock singer who like banter a
lot Adam and Blake I knew all about this
I'm just saying what about Alicia the
most important one I'll get to her and
Kelly shout out to Kelly Clarkson
what's her Twitter that's a good
question you could find it sure it's
awesome
you knocked off my train of thought I'm
sorry if you follow me on Twitter which
i shouted out earlier when when I was on
track in telling you about something on
this podcast you'll know that during the
voice my Twitter basically came a fan
account for my cousin Britton Buchanan
because you have to vote in order to get
people to win on the voice and daggone I
got a cousin who can sang man yeah he's
very talented
um even I've even I got on my Twitter
shout-out to read him CEO until you
finally find a way at the last minute I
got involved in that I don't promote
yeah so yeah that's all I tweeted about
for for a handful of weeks there I even
used like the but yeah I really checked
my pride at the door you did for my boy
Britton you probably lost some father
I've downloaded like I did I went
through all the hoops just like any
normal person who uses the Internet
I like man you're not normal I
downloaded the The Voice NBC app tone
and then I'm like tweeting us malware
man and it's like putting the app in my
tweets for people to download the app
you've got a virus but no horrible but
what am I supposed to do it's like my
boy my boys got to win this thing I got
to do my part took over my Twitter for
it well turns out I don't have that much
digital power because you gotta tweet
about other things of the guy's voice he
got second place
hey but quite an accomplishment it's
actually better to get second place cuz
I he hasn't told me any this this is
just speculation on my part speculation
is dawning I don't want to say anything
to incriminate him but I would just say
that my speculation I think it's better
to get second in terms of
obligations what you can do freedom
versus obligations he's back out here
making stuff happen musically I met him
for the first time yesterday I almost
got him to sing for me but he was just
me and him in the office and I'm backed
out the last second he did have his
guitar yeah at least the case right I
didn't open it so he's back out here and
he's staying at my house
yeah I'm glad Lee now is Alicia Keys
also staying in your house because
please say yes and then please tell me
what I can come over no and no no one
never you can come over I guess if
you're bringing me something like cash
so he tells me to start like I was in a
meeting he's recording the reason I
can't I can't say what he's doing that's
for him to say I can't make
announcements on this podcast about what
my boys doing that's for him that's for
him to say on his it shout out to him on
Instagram okay he's really he's moving
Jake Hannon he's moving and shaking yeah
he's getting stuff done musically I'm
excited for him I'm providing bedding
for him like a doma saw a place for him
to stay for two weeks he's moving and
shaking in Hollywood you need any tips
for how to care for someone who's
staying in your home cuz I got lots of
uh Chris he's great at that yeah he is I
mean she's not opposed to it I'm the
only one who likes I'm like a grumpy old
man who likes my space and doesn't like
the pressure of having to make other
people happy in my home my kids and wife
have given up on me helping them with
that many years ago um when he comes
into town hey I gotta throw him under
the bus here he's gonna kill me for
telling the story but it's I think it
I'm I think it will benefit us I think
there's something in this for us we're
good I'm glad you're talking about it
and it's a funny story and he's the butt
of the joke so I'm gonna go for okay he
gets he gets off the the airplane he
drops off his luggage and stuff here and
then he goes to a pop-up shop in
Hollywood there's these pop-up shops
that's part of them you know it's like a
fancy thing where is it's there and then
it's gone
and you better go and you better buy the
stuff while it's there he's so he's
fanatical about music I mean he's the
biggest Bruce Springsteen fan I was
elated when he texted me a picture of
meeting Bruce Springsteen with Alicia
Keys in New York a couple of weeks back
some plenty - living vicariously through
my cousin he's he's he's meeting his
heroes and then it's it it's fabulous
the boss turns out he also like he's
gotten into The Grateful Dead which is a
head-scratcher for me but um John
Mayer's involved in that now dead head
scratcher he's a dead yeah John Mayer is
taking Jerry Garcia's place for many
years now he's been touring with them is
he gonna replace him on the ice cream
good question I don't know I don't know
how you can make Cherry Garcia sound
like John Mayer anyway he's going to
there was a John cherry show in San
Diego and then the next night there's a
show here in Dodger Stadium he's going
to both of those oh wait yeah when you
become like a deadhead you I think the
thing the expectation is that you will
follow them from show to show one 26
minute song is not enough you need to
hear it the next night as well so he
goes to this pop-up shop right when he
lands because the Hollywood it's a
Grateful Dead pop-up shop turns out he's
gotta wait two hours out in the Sun when
I see him later he's like got a
horrendous partner Stan yeah he's
sunburned because he baked out there for
two hours he finally gets in there and
he's like looking around all he's a
sweatshirt he knew this stuff would be
expensive but it's like hey this is
special a pup and material thing I
thought was interesting as he talked
about how you wait in line and then they
let you in like one one or two he's done
to it - max Lee I like two people in
there at once it's like a private
shopping experience oh there's a those
you've been waiting and there's a lot of
pressure there's a lot of pressure once
you're in there yeah cuz you know that
everybody else's is outside and he's
looking around grabs a sweatshirt
sees a t-shirt full of t-shirt with a
like a hand-drawn design on it yeah no
price tags of course and he he goes up
to the register and then the only people
who were left in there are lining up
behind him and he said that the that the
girl at the register
in a condescending tone was like this
t-shirt is $500 is that gonna be okay
with you I just said that t-shirt is
$500 and it was one of the members of
the Grateful Dead in it no he didn't
realize this but it turns out it was a
one-of-a-kind art piece hand drawn on
that particular t-shirt by an artist
that we looked up later
and I mean I wouldn't know the artist
but he's known by people I guess know
about people he's not known enough for
them to charge 500 bucks for a t-shirt I
mean the original piece of art and poor
guy he was like I just felt the pressure
or the people behind me in line and I'd
picked out the shirt and so I was just
like yeah that'll be fine and I gave him
a credit card and then the idiot free
lodging and then the hoodie cost $90
okay all right
which I would have said was unreasonable
but then I would a minute okay it's a
pop-up shop and this deal the only place
you can buy it I looked at this shirt I
mean it just looks like some it looks
awesome $500 shirt it's a great-looking
lying you know writing with pin on a
shirt this is gonna he's gonna kill me
because I just don't know there's no way
he was gonna tell it but here I am laid
in a bit [ __ ] we can turn this around
for him because this is you gonna defray
the costs 2018 no 2018 is the year of
the resale man yes you got to turn it
around he'd better not wear it
eBay it you know he said right after he
left John Mayer showed up at the pop-up
and started taking pictures with people
they probably don't even buy one of
those shirts but he did Instagram a
picture of the shirt that Britain bought
oh so that's like an added thing when
you're like when you're reselling it on
eBay you're like an John Mayer Instagram
this t-shirt as well at the exact one or
these there's only one yeah so he he
instagrammed the like the online listing
like
that had already been taken because of
course Britain already had the shirt by
the time you need a teddy Miss very
shortly tell him not to wear it you got
a reason I mean oh he's not gonna wear
it he told me that I don't know he's got
he's got a budding music career though
500 bucks for a t-shirt that is the way
of the rock star it is so and this may
just be the beginning of the rest of his
life so is just coming home to my house
eating tacos and falling asleep halfway
through queer I Oh Ruben - episode one
yeah okay you fell asleep I mean I think
it was the jet lag riveting episode
well okay you know what I will buy the
freaking t-shirt from him I just feel
guilty sharing the story Britain I'm
gonna buy the t-shirt from you and then
resell it and the Marie Charlotte but
but we got to do a pop-up shop and we
got to start getting our ink on yeah
like ink drawing we're gonna be still
have $500 t-shirts John Mayer's gonna
show up it's as easy as that
I got a defray the cost of buying the
t-shirt off of my cousin I'm a framenet
puppy if you sell it in a frame you get
more on eBay that's what I'm thinking
speaking of pop-up frames
speaking of pop-up shops we do have to
sell some stuff these are not pop-up
these are just in a store mythical dot
store their mugs they say good luck with
that you going to a pop-up shop with
Grateful Dead merch good luck with that
you just bought a $500 t-shirt from an
artist - you can't quite remember who
they are good luck with that it works in
every scenario you're exploiting the
story of your cousin on a podcast and
now you feel guilty and need to buy the
$500 t-shirt from your cousin good luck
with that
see I think of all the situations that
you could apply this mug to and you can
also drink a beverage out of it dual
purpose mythical dot store I think he's
gonna kill me he can't kill me he's a
kid he's just 18 years old you don't
know what he's doing
buying t-shirt he's probably would be
better at killing you as an 18 year old
he's probably at his ability to kill
peak oh gosh yeah sleep with one eye
open okay gripping your pillow tight
speaking of
death in danger that is a danger in fun
how's that okay we are going to talk
about the balance between these two
things and we got the idea to explore
this question from a question from the
mythical beast known as Zane Phillips
who asked us what are your thoughts on
having fun at the potential of danger
for example I love to ride motorcycles
but I'm not allowed to because of
parental restrictions hmm even though I
fly gliders and small planes which can
be just as dangerous
you fly gliders in planes which okay so
so immediately I'm already questioning
well what is statistically more
dangerous motorcycles or gliders slashes
planes slashes you have multiple slashes
do you want me to do you want me to get
into the numbers do you answer that
question well where did you want to go
first
where's the first place your mind goes
with this because certainly as we've
gotten older and my life I feel like my
life is a lot more precious than it was
in my brain then it then when I was
younger
well that's part of being young that's a
good place to start is what do you think
your hour yours and mine philosophy was
when we were killing peak at 18 and what
is it and what is it now how does it
changed because we have done a lot of
dangerous things I wrote I consider
myself very risk-averse yes same time I
mean in a recent episode well a few
months back now we did give the I gave
the tongue-in-cheek advice to when
somehow related to danger and like what
people could do with their summers to go
kayaking like we did a lot of river
kayaking and we had a lot of near-death
experiences doing that and our our
families hated it and in retrospect I
mean I just can't imagine letting you
know every single thing that we're gonna
talk about
what with few exceptions that we did as
a kid his stuff I would never let my
kids do now and I don't even know how I
feel about that
I mean right because it's clarified the
kayaking do you remember this story I'd
love for you to retell the story of when
you took the USS Morrill your kayak
around the buoy squeak creak at the edge
of Keith ales golf course and it was at
flood stage yeah well yeah so to give
you the the background because every
experience is variable I think one of
the things that we'll probably explore
is the way you approach dangerous
situations that you have control over
that you can prepare for and you can
minimize danger when we kayaked
we maximize danger at least as far as
Buies Creek was concerned because I was
in a kayak
that was not we didn't fit me I as I
explained on a previous episode it had
flotation that existed of trash bags
filled with foam that I found in my
attic that was just pushed into the
front and back of the boat this very
homemade and janky could not flip the
kayak never figured out how to do that
well let's say roll if you can flip a
kayak that implies going head over like
tail over nose I even called it be quite
if we called it flip that's how unaware
I was of what was happening but I also
could not roll it and I don't believe
you ever control it Ben could roll it a
little behind so did not have a helmet
so just to clarify rolling is when you
when you turn the whole kayak upside
down and you're still stuck inside of it
but you're exposed torso and head are
facing directly down underwater and then
somehow you got to use the paddle in a
magical way to to continue your momentum
and come out the other side like a log
and some might argue that it is a
prerequisite for kayaking I would okay
especially that and an actual safety
course where we were is prerequisite but
the other thing we would do is the only
time we would break the kayaks out is
when the creeks flooded so when this
Creek that was about 10 to 15 feet wide
would flood it would
and it would suddenly overflow its banks
and it would just be this muddy river
that was like a rollercoaster incredibly
dangerous we would take it and we would
go through culverts like there were
these big culverts that were big enough
to put a man in like probably like a
five foot diameter yeah that was that
would fill up and be and shoot you out
we would go through these things in
kayaks yes it's crazy and you believe
that we did that I mean you could
literally be decapitated it was stupid
and but when he had this the spot of the
creek where it almost became like a
canyon the most canyon like spot on
Buies Creek where there's like a cliff
on one side this is along what used to
be hole number six at Keith Hills
Country Club which they switch the front
and back nine so whatever that is now
and you would start in one spot with all
in and everybody was up there and then
you couldn't walk along the creek up
because it was so steep so you'd walk
along the Gothel and then everyone would
be down on the other end waiting for you
to come out mm-hmm so while you're in
the middle of the the crazy Rapids there
was nobody who was there to help you
nobody who was there to see you and at
flood stage I mean the the creek which
becomes a torrential river basically
starts to incorporate a lot of obstacles
like trees going in all directions that
normally would just be beside and around
and sometimes spanning over top of in a
bridge like fashion the creek itself and
if I be incorporated into it along with
debris
so you and Ben went through first each
in our own kayak yeah and mine wasn't
janky I think you successfully navigated
it as far as I could tell yeah yeah yeah
and then we we get on the bank over
there and we we wait for you to come
through and you didn't so what happened
to me is I went around the bend and lost
my balance which happened all the time
in the USS Merle and of course when you
fall over in the
USS Merle and your ret you just get out
of the kayak you and you take it off
like pants yeah and so we did have a
skirt you know the skirt thing that
water skirt whatever it's known to keep
the water out so the kayak turns over
and I push myself out of the kayak and
then it basically as soon as I kind of
come up I realized that I am up against
a tree that is horizontally like a
bridge across the water that's just
under the surface of the water that you
could not see yeah and so I'm like up
against it it's it's again it's against
your pelvis and then and then I realize
if first of it was like no big deal let
me just go over this thing well the
kayak literally before I had a chance to
do that I feel the kayak itself which
has now turned sideways with the hull of
the kayak facing upstream yes is up
against me and filling and entirely with
water very quickly filling with water
and pressing all of its weight against
me this is flood stage up against the
tree and it had me pinned perfectly in
the middle of my body so I couldn't make
a decision to go upward I couldn't move
I remember just finally deciding to go
looking for you and we came back around
to the top and then started walking down
as far as we could I think we I can't
remember walked up or down but I
remember seeing you standing in the
middle of the creek well so from my
perspective I saw you guys way down like
around the bend and you remember it
differently than me because in my
version I was I fell behind you get fell
out of the kayak and then I was trying
to get your attention but you were like
a hundred yards downstream
and you kind of just look back I was
like yelling and like you look back and
just saw me because you kept going you
didn't you weren't coming to look for me
you were just continuing to finish your
trip that sounds right so but literally
at that moment I'm like I'm gonna die I
cannot get out of this I'm pushing up
I'm pushing a cannot get out of the
situation I'm like
this is going to crush me I'm not gonna
be able to get out of here I'm gonna
very soon I won't be able to breathe so
I start pushing up as hard as I can on
this log and thankfully what was
happening with the kayak because I had
crappy homemade homemade flotation is
that as the kayak filled up with water
it began to move down it began to sink a
little bit and that was just enough for
it to kind of slide down onto my butt
and let me scrape myself up and push
myself up and over the log I could have
broken your leg and I and I had these
scars I scars all over my hips from
where they you know rubbed against the
the tree the tree but it was just so
stupid on so many levels that we that we
did that but the question is was it
worth the fun was it worth the story
obviously our philosophy back then
because that's just one of many examples
we're gonna do some other ones but I
think our my philosophy at least was
what can we do today like there was no
like I consider myself like pretty
risk-averse like I wouldn't climb up in
things really high that I could like
fall out of if like we were going out as
a teenager yeah if we were like sui sui'
swung on vines all the time and like we
even though one of my initial back
injuries is a vine breaking for the most
part we would like make sure this is a
strong we didn't do it wasn't jackass we
weren't like purposely doing things we
were trying not to get hurt and
miraculously we did a lot of stuff and
never got hurt but I would never do 90%
of those things now because I'm
constantly worried about man if I get
hurt I won't be able to work this is
gonna be such an annoyance yeah because
I'm always a just about hurt anyway with
my back you know so I've completely
changed the way I approach these these
these things well even now if people
bring up things like skydiving or bungee
jumping my snap reaction is well I'm not
going to do
like that unless it's for a video you
know now to do something that's more
risky and I and I do think I absolutely
have my limits on what that would be I'm
not gonna do anything just for a video
but there are certain things that I'm
not gonna do just for the personal fun
of it but that might put me over the
edge so I actually think bungee jumping
I don't know what again you know the
number so you'll tell me eventually but
I don't I think I would do bungee
jumping for a video I just don't think I
think it's kind of tired so I don't
really see a good video in it and even
skydiving I I think I might do skydiving
but if I had to choose one it probably I
don't know cuz Scott having you do it
tandem but bungee jumping there's a
system I think I would I think I would
do bungee jumping before skydiving I
don't know which would you do first
before I mean just before you look at
numbers okay if you had to choose I
didn't see the numbers you I'm just
bringing it up I definitely think that
skydiving is safer than bungee jumping
and and and I would and I would do like
it's being it's been done so much longer
and you're just strapped to a guy who's
supposed to be in or a girl who's
supposed to be an expert as opposed to
just strapped to a rubber band it just
feels like something that's just got
onto ankles it's got so much right you
know regulation behind it like it's
because it's done so many times let's
look at the numbers skydiving you have a
one and 101,000 chance of dying while
skydiving okay one hundred and one
thousand bungee jumping you have a 1 in
500,000 oh my gosh it's a lot safer it's
5 times 5 times safer skydiving is five
times more dangerously okay and you know
I have a theory I have a general theory
that so I made the right choice you made
the wrong choice here's my other one
these are more extreme but doesn't it
seem scarier though hang gliding okay
hang gliding versus ziplining now
they're not even in the same ballpark
obviously I've been ziplining many times
but hang gliding even tandem I mean it's
up to there's so many variables but it's
up to the end of one individual to bob
and weave and react to whatever happens
in that instance versus a system like a
mechanical system has been put in place
it's it's subject to frequent inspection
and proof okay so every single time
you're not you're not just going out
there and leaving it up to a lot of
human moment by moments right by second
judgment well okay first of all these
I'm the stats that I'm getting right now
from Teton Gravity calm so that's why I
like replying pulling from a couple
different places so I've done ziplining
a lot you've done ziplining - I have no
okay
so pretty consistent with what you're
saying hang gliding you have a 1 in 560
560 oh not 500,000 560 so hang gliding
yeah is extremely dangerous there's a
guy at the end of my street who has a
hang glider and I was I was just looking
at the thing and I got sweaty palms now
like you were saying okay so the guy at
the end of your street if I were to tell
him that he has a 1 in 560 chance of
dying and Hank and a hang glider he
would say well not me that might be the
overall statistics but he would be like
I had it's a safe as riding in a car for
me he may he may make that claim because
he's in control so I do want to because
he'll probably say something about
because I only elect to do it when the
conditions are right Victor but the fact
is regardless of how you approach it it
is it is an extremely dangerous activity
because there are certain things that
are outside of your control
even if
you're an expert so maybe your
individual odds would be lower than that
but it is on a whole a very dangerous
thing to do now ziplining something that
we both done and we've both done it with
our families oh yeah my kids love to do
it I've done it I've done it in like
there was this private like near Santa
Cruz camp that you did it in the top of
these redwoods in a forest it was
amazing
done it I talked about doing it in
Mexico and we did in Hawaii and I'm
scared of heights
ironically and it can be kind of
paralyzing like I think I'm actually
like we did that ropes course at the
Central Florida Zoo for some reason the
Central Florida Zoo has a ropes course
because every Zoo should don't fall into
the lion enclosure and you're like you
know 10 to 20 feet in the air given on
given where you're at on the course and
you're strapped into a guide or guide
wire but I get paralyzed in those
situations because it's it's
inconsistent like I'm trying to balance
and then I might fall and that thing is
gonna pull and like I don't like that
situation I'm much more comfortable with
ziplining because once I throw my weight
on a zipline it's kind of a consistent
experience mm-hmm but I am constantly
thinking am I gonna be the guy that
breaks the zipline and dies and even
when my kids are like we did Costa Rica
a couple years ago and I'm a few years
of four years ago probably and Shepherd
was so small there was a few things that
he was - it was not heavy enough it was
not heavy enough but it was also through
the jungle and over these like ravines
and stuff and it was all these Costa
Rican guys that a few of them spoke
English a lot of them didn't are just
like I'm just like gesturing with
Shepherd I'm like hand them this kid and
they like strap him in they're like give
me the thumbs-up and like push him and I
don't where did he go and then I see him
a little bit later
but you you that's a tremendous amount
of trust but I had him dude I had
embraced it I was like it's probably not
as safe as the trip that we took to get
here but I think it's one in a million
I think ziplining is
chance of these our chance of fatality
right I don't have a number for you you
know I looked up ziplining and it has
it's so that they don't have any
variables so many of you they don't have
any statistics that have been gathered
there's like lots of reports of people
dying or getting injured but it's kind
of difficult to know how many people did
it's still a relatively new activity so
at least in like a 5 to 10 minute
dive onto the Internet but the bottom
line is it's incredibly variable so you
got to know who's controlling this
zipline like how often do they check
their stuff how there's so many
variables it's not like it's not as
regulated but I guess that is the case
with like skydiving and hang gliding
whatever it's just your equipment is a
huge part of it and you just got to know
you got to know it like every single
variable is taken care of and it's as
safe as possible when it but when are
you unlikely that's you're gonna get
hurt but when the TripAdvisor reviews
are all positive and if there's a system
in place
I just I'm I'm able to just check out
like what I'm doing all that I'm never
I'm not looking at the equipment III
feel like I need to like up my game a
little bit to at least think about what
would I contingency plans you know well
if this thing that I just clamped on up
here is my safety line if that did fail
what would I do
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna grab it I'm
gonna get the worst rope run of my life
but I'm not gonna fall I'm gonna grab
this thing you know I think I could do
better but I I kind of feel like it's a
gift that like I'm able to trust a
system like going to I mean getting on a
rollercoaster it about every year you
hear some rollercoaster malfunctioned I
mean this months ago wasn't it at Six
Flags that like where we've been
multiple times people people like
falling 30 feet and in like a
rollercoaster car I mean that happened
yet again right now one rule of thumb
that you could apply to
this is is the thing I'm going to do
more dangerous than the transportation
required to get there okay just to think
about that for a second if it's not then
that makes you feel okay I can do this
now this is and nothing this is this is
a really relatable thing because a lot
of people are afraid of flying right
yeah and but they have absolutely no
problem with taking the trip to the
airport now you've probably heard
countless times that the trip to the
airport is a lot more dangerous than the
actual flight that is 100% true so
here's what your if you get to the
airport in a luge right I'm assuming
you're going in a motor vehicle not a
motorcycle because we're going to talk
about motorcycles in a second because
that was one of the things that Zane
mentioned okay I want to get this right
okay so according to stats from the US
National Highway Traffic Safety
Administration actually and now I'm
getting two motorcycles here we go
travel by car is many times more deadly
per mile than commercial air travel it's
not even close it's not even worth
bringing up what the numbers are because
there's a number of different ways you
can do it but lifetime odds of death for
selected causes injury facts die NSC org
your chances of dying in a motor vehicle
crash are 1 and 102 whoa okay so you
have like a bottle choices of what being
injured note dying oh gosh the chance is
that any given person and the US is
gonna die in a car wreck is about 1% one
in 102 so whoa that's not really
comparable to you know when we talked
about the they calculate the stats in
different ways but okay the chances you
dying of cancer are one in seven okay
so one in seven people are going to die
of cancer this is taking a depressing
turn I thought we were talking about
having fun now the chances of you nobody
by the way nobody gets cancer for the
fun of it so but
but so you digress but go ahead the
chances of dying on a passenger airplane
is one and 205,000
really 102 and 205 552 thousand so a
small small fraction in fact on this
list it is the least likely way to die
right next to dying on a train which is
one in 117 9,000 dog attack is 1 in 133
thousand lightning strike 1 and 140
you're more likely to die of a dog
attack than you are are lightning than
you are with a dog attack which is more
likely than on a train which is more
likely than on an airplane so you need
to if you're scared to fly you need to
never go outside during a storm
definitely and you need to stay away
from dogs and you need to definitely
never travel on it on a train now we'll
let you off the hook people who are
afraid of flying and we I know it
doesn't work this way for you this type
of logic doesn't help you and you got to
get at this another way so I just want
to acknowledge that for the sake of the
loved ones close to me that I've flown
with and no but but but hold on ok no I
know yeah
so people have a phobia of flying and
it's and it's not based in logic no but
I do think that the truth of the stats
it can't hurt they're not irrelevant no
they are actually the most relevant
thing in reality now but that doesn't
include cuz but it's just not you know
just talking about that is not an
effective treatment it's just part of it
right do you got it but the two that
there's two different things so I think
a lot of people are like I want to get a
motorcycle just like Zane I want to get
a motorcycle and then some people and
then I have always talked to my wife
about how at some point you know when
I'm in my second midlife crisis I would
like to learn how to fly plane and she's
like you can't fly a plane because it's
super dangerous to fly a plane and her
parents were actually and she was there
too she was one year old they had to
take an emergency trip up
Detroit when my father-in-law's father
was shot and they had to go to see him
in the hospital and they took they like
chartered a private plane and they're
coming back from the trip coming back
into Raleigh and it's just the pilot and
the my mother and father-in-law and then
Jess and Jesse and I guess actually her
sister was there they clipped a power
line coming in and a crash landing that
was no one got seriously hurt I don't
think anybody got even maybe just some
bumps and scratches or whatever bumps
and bruises but so she's been enough
plane crash my wife has been in a plane
crash and then we've know people who've
had people died in plane crashes
whatever so interestingly yeah but a but
the stats are on her side because so
travel by car is many times more deadly
a per mile than commercial air travel
however general aviation which is a
broad category but does include private
planes small planes is many times more
deadly per mile than car so general
aviation is roughly 20 times more
dangerous per hour than driving ouch so
she's actually right hopefully a good
thing she doesn't listen to this podcast
because flying I am still why still want
to be a pilot at some point but the
thing about motorcycles is and I'm not
riding with you after hearing this I'm
out you know we're talking about things
like bungee jumping or skydiving and
trying to wait is the is the fun worth
the danger but for most people none of
those things would even be considered
fun I mean it's like hey let's strap a
rubber band to your ankles and dangle
you off of off a cliff know off a bridge
no better yet why don't you jump and
then look like you're gonna do a
faceplant and then bounce back and forth
a few times won't that be fun but and
you might die a motorcycle is a fun job
motorcycle seems fun and but I would say
go-karting
is something that seemed really fun
until I did it the last time we did it
and daggone if my back and neck wasn't
hurting so bad I'm like it I don't think
it would it could kill me but it could
it could maim me like you could easily
be maimed in the in the back or neck
region from from go-karting at those
aggressive speeds and you're like tight
corners and bumps we're getting
rear-ended don't you remember
oh you mean in the oh oh you're talking
about about the go kart racing thing
inside the place yeah I thought you
talked about the go kart that you bought
for your family that you guys did on the
road for like 24 hours of it yeah they
didn't they didn't go for that I did buy
one of those yeah I was like that is the
most unlinked Neil like thing ever he
bought a go-kart yeah from my neighbor
and then you sold it because Lincoln was
afraid to drive it he probably was onto
something yeah but okay so I I thought
go-karting would be fun and now I'm like
it's not worth the danger given how I
want to keep my body in in working order
a hundred percent agreed and I think I
mean even more so I don't even know the
status on motorcycles but I I know
enough people who've had like a scooter
or motorcycle and then they've had this
wake-up call and then they've decided to
get rid of okay well this is the stat
that I was about to read from the
National Highway Traffic Safety
Administration per vehicle mile traveled
motorcyclist risks of a fatal crash is
35 times greater than a passenger car so
while you're in this other list I was
looking at your chances of dying in a
motorcycle crash if you're just any any
old person or lower but that's but that
didn't take into account the fact that
well most people don't ride motorcycles
so the only real way to do it is per
vehicle mile traveled so 35 times
greater fatality risk per mile than a
car than a car and we already said that
there's a 1 in 102 chance of you dying
in a car so this is already what if
alone about most driving in car like
remotely using his robots so ok so that
number goes down I believe yeah
so I think that anyone motorcycle bad
news because and you may say well that's
people who can't drive but motorcycles
are the greatest example of something
that the idiots that you have no control
over on the road you're subject to their
idiocy while you are driving because mhm
and I've seen it a million times out
here so in LA you can you can split
lanes it's legal a lot of people first
move out here in the leg what does that
guard doing well actually if you don't
get more than like 15 miles per hour
over the speed of the people I think it
is the number it is legal to split lanes
just to clarify that means you're
driving bumper-to-bumper traffic but
also lane to lane you're like tracking
with people if you're not going more
than 50 miles an hour a motorcycle can
drive in between two cars there at a
like the right beside each other
yeah and a lot of think this'll speed
differences on these on the basically on
the painted line and you'll hear you
you'll hear or see them coming and
you'll like you'll try to get I try to
move over try to get over a little bit
but as evidenced by the fact that just
the other day I did that and I moved
over and when a guy went by me he gave
me the thumbs up yeah not everybody
moves over and some people don't even
see some people have no awareness of
what's behind them and I'm not gonna put
myself and you shall remain nameless I
am NOT going to put myself in that
situation although it seems real cool
and it seems real fun for me and it also
seems a lot quicker to get somewhere in
LA and also making a decision I think
this is another factor that goes into
the rubric ziplining bungee jumping
skydiving you don't do these things to
get from point A to point B you don't
commute by bungees by bungee cord just
for fun because if you do you get pulled
back to your original destination which
is not much of a commute nope and also
you better be uphill if you're gonna zip
line you have to commute one way uh
there's many times where I'm in a
situation where I'm
the end of a hike and I'm like man if
there was a zipline back down to the car
it would be awesome but typically it is
something you do you expose yourself to
this dangerous activity for a very brief
moment with motorcycles because the way
that we calculate the risk is per mile
if you decide that you're gonna get a
motorcycle you're probably going to go
on road trips you're gonna use it you
might use it to commute you might say
well this is the way that I avoid
traffic in Los Angeles
you're leaving beds you're building up
your risk with every mile and I so I
think that's part of it I'm not gonna
choose to do that because but I might
say hey for a video okay for buddy
system season 2 we both run a motorcycle
remember that you were in the sidecar
yeah I tend to not think of it as a
motorcycle because of the sidecar and so
you know that was a motorcycle it was a
closed course it was you did not know I
didn't know what I was doing and I
didn't get was also like a 19-15 bike or
something like that that was very
difficult to start didn't get very fast
and it had a sidecar so you couldn't it
couldn't fall no I'm easier to see
but I'm willing to take the risk if it's
isolated what you weren't on the
interstate know exactly what I'm saying
yeah I'm not adjust I'll never ride a
motorcycle guy but I'm not gonna buy a
motorcycle as a means of transportation
because at that point I introduced
myself to risk levels that are
unbearable now what about when we were
in Nice and we rented those scooters and
we drove very dangerous we drove on like
the cliffside highway to Monaco yeah
that was in you know what I had so much
fun and I was I was so scared one of the
best moments of my life it was so much
fun I would you do that again I would
and here's why I would do it that was it
that was pretty risky it was very
high-risk but what were the chances of
us having serious injury or death in
choosing to do that for one day out of
our entire lives and it may be a second
day now if we haven't given that I had
never ridden a scooter before in my life
and before
let Kristy get on behind me I went
around the block and nearly ran into a
building because I couldn't keep the
things straight that's pretty crazy yeah
okay maybe it wasn't wise but was it I
just didn't tell Christie that I almost
had an accident around the corner after
I left her site but but seriously if you
decided if you told me I'm moving to
France and I'm going to use a scooter
exclusively to get around then I'd be
like link for a number of reasons this
is not a good idea
because I don't know how this
partnership is gonna continue to work if
you're gonna be in France but beyond
that if you're gonna travel by scooter
alone I I don't think that's super safe
especially one that can only go 25 miles
per hour because we didn't have a
motorcycle license to be able to get the
one with the CCS
you know required to get up to highway
speeds so I think it's about the the
amount of exposure well but then
controlling that I mean even think about
hiking do you have numbers on hiking
because I mean I knew we we decided we
were going to talk about this subject
matter a few days ago but then as of the
recording of this this morning we heard
the news of course by the time you
hearing this is much later but that
three youtubers died going over a
waterfall in British Columbia from the
YouTube channel high on life to guys
like um it's unclear but as far as I can
read they were swimming in a pool with a
waterfall with a at a high elevation and
there was a waterfall going into it and
a waterfall going out of it and the
girlfriend went oh started to go over
the guy tried to save her he started to
go over and and the other guy his friend
tried to save him sorry I don't know
that we don't we don't know that a lot
of the details either they all went over
and died and it's not clear if they if
they if she fell in or if they were all
swimming but I mean they if you look at
their YouTube channel they certainly
lived a life of adventure on the
edge and you know they maybe that was a
calculated risk but they didn't
calculate it properly and it reminds me
of and my heart goes out to you know I
don't want to belittle it my heart goes
out to family and friends associated
with that it's a it's a tragedy it
freaks me out when I'm going hiking like
even at the Grand Canyon when I went
with the kids and there's there's those
that more adventurous people who go over
the railings and then they go out on the
edges and then start doing handstands
and whatnot just dangerous and that's
fun for them you know but there's well I
don't I I don't get that there's
something in my body like literally when
I get to the edge of a cliff like it
make ice my balls feel pain hmm like do
you feel that when you get played out
well no when you get to the balls feel
pain in my balls okay when you get that
connection when you get to the edge of a
cliff or at a at a height I don't you
felt like you could fall it I don't have
ball pain like my other things a stomach
see my stomach hurt yeah yeah that
happens but maybe to get your balls like
that I know maybe that's a common thing
I keep my balls in my stomach
did I not say that no I I'm very scared
of heights I have to I don't get those
people through my meaning it's not that
it might be fun to take a picture out
there but to do it that's well a
handstand genetically there is some
there is a different mentality I mean
those people's brains are different than
our brain that's just risk-takers have
different brains it mapped now the the
youtubers who died I wasn't I didn't
know anything about their channel I
looked at it a little bit and it seemed
like they were they were having fun I
mean high on life they were having all
kinds of fun
they were inspiring people there's lots
of people who have been inspired to go
and to do big things and so I think that
again it's it's striking a balance and I
and I don't know anything about what
they were doing we just happen it was
just in the on the news like yesterday
from
recording this so we don't know exactly
what happened and they're not obviously
not to be blamed it was an accident
however went down but I think that
people who take risks and live big lives
and do big things it comes with the
territory that you're going to have a
risk of dying but you're dying doing
something you love and so I think it's
more about what is your personal
approach to this and I think that
ultimately it can be taken this is just
my analysis of it it can be taken too
far in both extremes so you've got
people who are so risk-averse that they
won't fly they won't get in a car they
won't do the everyday things that you
kind of and also they limit themselves
from just every once in a while having
fun is what I'm not getting on hold I'm
not gonna ride on that horse yeah
whatever it might be and then there are
people who you know like steve-o used to
be who is I'm gonna take a risk for the
for the adrenaline rush that it is and
they're kind of off the other end of the
spectrum and I and I think that living
somewhere in a place where you there's a
realistic assessment of the danger but
also not an unrealistic avoidance of
risk because you know you get one you
get one shot you get one shot at this
which means you need to be careful but
don't make it a miserable existence
because you're being careful I mean
that's why I like to enter into fun
experiences that are subject to a system
that has been built time-tested and
constantly tested you know so the
zipline anything or like riding a mule
down the Grand Canyon my family was
petrified to do that but like I was like
there's data that says how safe this is
the thing that gets me is I mean as a
dad now I freaked out looking back at
how rash our decisions were
a cliff-diving we did that you know in
there was a rock quarry just outside of
Lillington where we grew up and it was
filled with water it was like 50 foot
deep hole filled with water but then the
far side of it it's called Acapulco Lake
and it was closed
turns out they open it on holidays and
some weekends and let people swim there
and know what no lifeguards at least as
of three years ago like the the latest
news article that I read which I was
reading about lots a senior and from
harness Central who who drowned who most
the time people get drunk and they jump
on top of each other that's how you die
out there yeah so there's a cliff on the
far side that if you can drive up and
park on the street and you can you can
find a hole or jump over the fence and
you can jump off this cliff and you know
we always felt like it was like a
50-foot cliff it may have been only been
30 foot but it's definitely tall enough
to where you jump off and you get scared
twice you know you know that if you it's
a cliff when you get scared twice you
know you get scared and then you're like
oh I'm just just never gonna end
and you're like you lose your breath and
if you were much more confident jumping
off of this thing but like there was no
calculating of risks it was just
calculating of peer pressure well but
okay so I looked up some cliff diving
stuff and cliff diving again it's one of
those things that there's so many
variables it sure it's not regulated I
mean that nobody really gather stats on
it because what is a cliff dive like
kids jumping into a rock quarry you know
it's dangerous but people going up on
cliffs on the ocean side and you jumping
into something you don't really know the
depth of and you're the first person to
do it you're more like if it's an
established spot where people have been
jumping off this for years and you've
seen a bunch of people go before you and
the current is not crazy again there's
so many variables you kind of have to
just assess it in the moment yeah but
there's multiple deaths that this place
that we went
and we never thought about that it was
just like one of us was like on a day
are saying let's go to this place what
if we went off but would you let your
kids do it now no not well with me now
see I would let Locke do it because not
at a place that is not open to the
public and there's not no I'm not
talking about sneaking in I wouldn't
sneak in and do it but like we snuck in
in at night it was like 1:00 a.m. a girl
you remember that a group of our friends
we all went there yeah and we jumped off
in the dark you got you couldn't see the
edge of the cliff that hardly you
couldn't see the water and you can see
the water and we're jumping off of this
thing I was that was not stupid it was
not smart again the way we approached it
in that given situation was not smart
but like we didn't end up doing this but
we went to Hawaii last year you know
luck is a platform driver and he's not
scared of heights and he can do stuff
off ten meter or whatever there was this
famous cliff diving spot in on the Big
Island that we were gonna go to but
ended up being really far away and we
didn't go but I kind of prepared myself
I talked to my brother who had done it
with his son and he was like just
checked the current that day see if
anybody else is doing it so it's like
calculated risk and again I'm not making
the decision to become as a vocation a
cliff diver I'm just doing it on
vacation one time and it's not like I'm
the first person to I think beer a
minute this I calculated an informed
risk is something that I feel they need
to I mean our kids don't have nearly the
amount of freedom that we had based on a
whole bunch of variables
well time space location everything but
right you know I just want to instill in
my kids whether it's whatever it is
they're deciding to do it's like okay
stop think about the risks you know
yeah just calculate it do it do it I
think that that rough calculation is
actually a great way to do this now what
I don't before we go out one thing I
want to talk about just because we've
got experienced with with this having
been in Amsterdam is the Dutch P
everybody in Amsterdam in the
Netherlands in general they're riding
bikes around like
no one has on a helmet okay right yeah
in fact unless they are our wives and
kids because when we decided to rent
bikes they were like we've got it you
we've got to wear helmets and we were
like I don't want to wear a helmet
because then it's obvious that were the
American tourists because no one else is
doing it so me and you didn't wear
helmets but our wives and our kids did
now interestingly they don't wear
helmets as a policy they do not wear
helmets and the Dutch have the lowest
cycling death an injury rate in the
world but as a culture now first of all
in the u.s. everybody it's not the 80s
anymore everybody wears a helmet but we
have a significantly higher you know
bike bicycle death and injury rate than
in the Dutch too now there's a number of
reasons that are given for this most
people tend to think that it's just
because well first of all the reason
they don't wear helmets is because they
use their bikes as a form of
transportation that go everywhere so
when you have to put on a helmet all of
a sudden you've got a helmet that you
have to worry about and also you've got
the hair situation which incidentally
that is the best theory so far that
people have surmised as to why they
don't wear helmets is because we are
using this all the time and if we wore
helmets our hair would because we
constantly have helmet hair mm-hmm right
that's important and so they don't wear
helmets but yeah and why are they safer
I mean it's also very flat there do you
know and there's a society of being when
there's so many bikes and everything's
built for bikes I think it makes
everything safer too so there's a
society of safeness well you remember
the the kids we go along and there'd be
a dad on his bike and there would be his
kid would be on his shoulders on the
bike like lots of this any safety but I
hold on it is safe in the way that they
do it so what why do you say it's safer
basically what you said they have a
culture that is bike friendly they have
lots of bike lanes there is respect
for people on bikes for with from the
people who are in the cars the bike has
the right away you notice that the
pedestrian does not have the right away
in Amsterdam the bike has the right away
and they tell you that a million times
when you're running a bike they've got
the right away they've got adequate
lanes there's enough of there's a
momentum because there's so many people
doing it right that they're not going
SuperDuper fast they're they're going at
a reasonable speed they've calculated
the risk and they've actually put
themselves in a place where they don't
have to wear helmets I don't think the
application this is not an argument for
not wearing a helmet this is arguing for
moving to Holland yeah so if you're
anywhere but the Netherlands in any
place like it wear a helmet definitely
in the US where element because people
ain't got no respect for people on bikes
especially in this town and so there's
actually a really high incidence of bike
deaths in the u.s. because there's just
a lack of respect for people on bicycles
but what the Dutch have also found is
that in places that have made helmets
mandatory biking rates have gone down
significantly so when you make people
have to wear a helmet less people bike
because they don't want to wear a helmet
and so then you get into the thing where
there's less people exercising and now
their risk of cardiovascular disease
goes up which in therefore increases the
death so when you look at the thing on a
whole it's actually safer for these
particular people in this particular
culture to not wear helmets so we go
over there as Americans were like these
people are nuts they need to put helmets
on they don't need to put bike helmets
on they need to stop smoking that's what
they need you right who's smoking that's
the real killer right 22 times more
likely to die of lung cancer if you're a
male who smokes 12 times more likely to
die of lung cancer if you're a female of
smokes
so stop smoking but if you're in if
you're Dutch don't start wearing a
helmet again it's not oh if you're in
the nose not just be just because you're
of Dutch heritage doesn't mean you get
the a special power but so again I just
thought you can't apply a hard and fast
rule I think you can do risky things if
you're doing them real quickly yeah
you're not
doing them often and you're not making a
habit out of one risky thing like if you
want to be a hang-glider
and that's gonna be your pastime there's
a great chance that you're gonna die
hang gliding
what about highlining you want to do
that you know what that is that's like
on the bouncy wire thing yeah but really
high like spanning mountaintops but you
can still clip in so when you're
tightrope walking and you decide to do
your little tricky dick and then you
fall tricky doo doo dah okay
I made up a word I don't know as a
policy I try not to do tricky dick yeah
that's a really painful and unless I'm
in Holland in Amsterdam specifically you
can guess what it is I don't know but I
will say that when tightrope walking it
is a very painful thing to do but it's
but it's very cool to pull off I don't
and they do the low line at Venice Beach
yeah the high line is you're in between
two mountains and then if you fall off
tricky doo dah you you get you get
caught by your you hang you down flipper
you hang you down clipper he was caught
by his hanging down and that's why
tonight rickety ding link Neil
attempting the tricky dick we're just
hoping that his hanging down will save
everything it's more fun to talk about
it than it is to try it yeah I wouldn't
do that because it wouldn't be fun for
me I wouldn't even watch I wouldn't do
it cuz it's not fun because my fear is
so high in the moment that the fun is
canceled out but ziplining I can let go
of it literally I can let go and you
just zip diddy Doo Dah Trickett e dick
right now in the zipline okay cuz thats
hanging down the whole time right you're
already hanging you down right it's like
it's like a it's like a Highline that
has broken and then slides that's what a
zipline is so again I'm not constantly
having to like correct and
thank for myself would you skydive yes
would you bungee jump no even though
even though we just learned what is five
times as dangerous but it's not nearly
as fun sounding to you the freefall the
whole time that I was on the bungee cord
I would be thinking about it breaking
even though probably I think I would
probably be thinking about the chute not
opening until it opened but the idea of
getting up there and flat the idea of
flying in general is something that I've
always been fascinated with and I think
skydiving is as close as you can get I'm
not gonna do the squirrel that's the
most dangerous thing it has to be a
squirrel suit thing yeah yes that's when
you like platform jump or what's it
called base jump well off of a sheer
face yeah and then you're sitting there
pulling you're pulling your arms out and
exposing your your squirrel wings and
that is absolutely true the most
dangerous sport in the assorted sports
category at this website is BASE jumping
with a one in sixty chance of death so
you take sixty BASE jumps you might die
you might die on your first one
that's how statistics work so yeah and
if you're doing this the squirrel suit
thing which is as which is a few levels
up from BASE jumping well you're like
trying to hover when you're flapping
that you don't flap oh I've seen some
flappers that you're in real trouble if
you're flapping in a squirrel suit gotta
be taut man you gotta be tight yeah I
would not do that but I'd wear one of
those squirrel suits while skydiving
which is different I'm sure that the
instructor would not allow it always
like whoa whoa whoa no squirrel suits
buddy you can't steer No yes along for
the ride I'm just saying that like down
the road let me think about that to be
able to jump off jump out of a plane
until I move a horizontal distance of an
impressive amount if I end up in another
County that'd be cool so you're saying
you would do it yeah but but also I yeah
i know i'm not gonna base jump but i was
will
kind of and what I will say also I agree
I'm not gonna do it if it's not for a
video but if it was for video I would do
it you will skydive in a video yes but
it won't be a good video so we're not
gonna yes just a skydiving video they
make it for you they do it for every but
I don't have to take a crew because they
do it and they put weird van Halen music
under it right yeah without paying van
Halen don't cut don't cut out
van Halen yeah shoo van Halen deserves
it don't make that mistake is royalties
from skydiving videos it's like the type
of guy you'd meet at a party it's like
what what do you do for a living
well I wrote this song one time it
sounded kind of like van Halen
turns out all the skydiving outfits use
it and I make Bank every month I get a
chance okay so do we have a rubric I
think I've stated my rubric a couple of
times now I'm gonna take risks but I'm
gonna take them in small quantities and
I'm going to assess the situation and
all the variables as best I can in the
moment for me and my family I think my
rubric is that plus if I'm not
comfortable off to do it with my kids
I'm not gonna do it okay
like if I'm not willing to put them at
risk then I'm not gonna put myself at
risk of leaving them to walk this earth
without me got it I like that I'll add
that to my rubric which some places guys
let's all strap on a squirrel suit I'm
not a hundred my rubric I'm not a
hundred percent sure that we've been
using it correctly
we haven't I mean at merriam-webster
calm an authoritative rule a rule for
conduct okay I think that could connect
at work an explanatory or introductory
commentary an established rule tradition
or custom a guide listing specific
criteria for grading or scoring academic
papers projects or tests
um I think that you know it's all in
combining that guy
for scoring things like our good to bad
decisions good to bad decisions fun
versus danger all right guys
we're gonna shut her down we're
approaching the edge of the cliff we've
got our suits on we got our hangy downs
dangling we're gonna clip it on and
tricky to dicker right out of here
but we'll be back again next week tricky
to Dixon hand yes I took God took too
far I took it too far I'm sorry go yeah
just let it go like a zip line you know
it it'll hold you it'll hold you they'll
catch you at the bottom
hashtag ear biscuits must continue to
conversate let's do that
bye-bye now
[Music]